[Musique]
un 22 septembre au diable vous
partites et depuis chaque année à la
date
suddite je mouillis mon
mouchoir en souvenir de vous or nous y
revoilà mais je reste de
[Musique]
Pier plus une seule larme à me mettre
aux
paupières
le 22 de septembre
aujourd'hui je m'en
fous jadis ouvrant mes bras comme une
paire
d'ail je montais jusqu'au ciel pour
suivre
l'hirondelle et me romper les
EAU en souvenir de
vous le complexe d'IC à présent ma
abandonne l'hirondelle en partant ne
fera plus
l'automne le 22
septembre
aujourd'hui je m'en
fous on ne reverra plus autant des
feuilles
mortes cet â en peine qui me ressemble
qui
porte le deuil de chaque
feuille en souvenir de
vous que le brave prév et ses escargots
veuillill bien se passer de moi pour
enterrer les
feuilles le 22
septembre
aujourd'hui je m'en
fou
pilleusement noué d'un bout de vos
dentellavis sur ma fenêtre un bouquet
d'immortel que j'arrosais de
pleur en souvenir de
vous je m'en vais les offrir au premiers
morts qui
passent les regrets éternels à présent
me
dépassent le 22
septembre aujourd'hui je m'en fous
désormais le petit bout de C qui me
reste ne traversera plus
l'Équinox
funestes en battant la
breloque en souvenir de
vous il a craché sa flamme et ses
cendres
sétigne à peine pourrait-on
retire
chatteigne le vin de
Satan aujourd'hui je m'en
fous et c'est triste de n'être plus
triste sans
[Musique]
vous